get you to your fourth one which is the
chiefs here they are just like you said
even at their worst point this season
they'll be back at the top of the afc
and here they are how'd they get here
how'd they get to this point in the
season despite their struggles
well obviously the defense you talk
about leadership and and making an
impact melvin ingram he's come in he's
made a difference he's been a big
difference maker you look at chris jones
and i always say with leadership
leadership isn't just about talking but
it's out there performing and making a
difference and chris jones has really
dominated the inside of that defense and
you look at some of those young
linebackers you look at the growth of
the secondary led by tyron matthew and
he's not what you would call a very
physical safety you know
coming up hitting 230 pound backs but
he's a guy that knows how to position
himself because he's a smaller guy but
he creates a lot of turnovers and he
keeps those guys he communicates with
him i just like what they've done on the
defensive side of the ball they have a
lot of depth in the secondary and really
for me i think it comes down offensively
to the growth and the patience of
patrick mahomes this is what we're
starting to see and patrick mahomes and
andy reid has been drilling to him if
you see that cover too don't be afraid
to drop you know dunk dink the ball off
just dump it off and i think he's done a
really good job of that even though
against the chargers they started
playing some cover three and some
man-to-man coverage he lit him up with
four touchdowns and over 400 yards so
patrick mahomes is the type of player my
whole point is this jack patrick mahomes
is now he's maturing into the type of
player where if he sees the two safeties
he's patient enough to dump it down if
he sees the one then he's gonna take
shots and of course he's got that boy
travis kelsey that's right it's the
maturity factor and they're going to
have to navigate some interesting
coveted stuff too because they had
tyreek hill show up with the positive
they had travis kelsey who's on the list
as well they got harrison buckers on the
list as well that's three tough ones and
they're getting ready to face the afc
north pittsburgh and the bengals they
have coming up down the stretch so both
those teams can get dangerous if you're
shorthand
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports